ان نتقد نتقبل تهديدات لشخصيات عامه وعلى
ابناء عائلاتهم
كما يحدث في هذه الاثناء
انا خلوني
لن نقبل
لا في حواره
ولا في الشوارع ولا في اي مكان
لقد اعطيتهم اسئله
واريد ان اعطيكم الان مثلا
مخالفا كيف يجب ان يقول الاحتجاج
قبل 20 عاما
كان هناك نقاش لا يقل جدلا ولا يقول لي
هزا للمشاعر كان هناك
الكثير من المواطنين الذين عارضوا لحياسه
الحكومه
واحس بان عالمهم خرب
في قضيه فك الارتباط ولما لا مش منتبه
لا اكثر من 8000 اسرائيلي من بيوتهم
وان يخرج الناس الموتى من القبور
وتقلع
السوطنات
[موسيقى]
وهذا كان بالنسبه
الثالث
وخرجوا في مواجهه ونضال قوي
وهذا شمل قطاعات واسعه من الشعب واقول
شيئا
هذا هذا
[موسيقى]
النضال لم يشتد هذه الخطوط لم نرى اليوم
لم
يعتدي
المتظاهرون على الشرطه
ولم يخرج اموالهم من الدوله
ولم يحرضوا على اسرائيل في العالم
لا لم ندعو الى لم ندعو حينها الى رصد
الخدمه العسكريه او الى شل المرافق
الاقتصاديه
ولم نحاول ان نقود الدوله الى فوضى
المختصر
لم نجتز خطوط الحمراء
ولكن في تلك الفتره عندما كانت معارضه تحت
رئاسته
بمسؤوليه ولكن اليوم المعارضه تتصرف بدونه
المعارضه تقول وانا اقتب
نكت افقد رئيس حزب اخر يحرض على المظاهرات
الازمه الدستوريه الى انتخابات شديده
واقول شيئا اضافيا
اعرف انها ليس الجميع
في المعارضه
هناك من يعارض الخط المتطرف
ويحفظون من العمليات
الشعبويه
المنظمه ايضا من قبل
عوامل داخليه وخارجيه
الى هؤلاء الناس المسؤولين
اقول لكم شيئا اضافيا
اذا لم نقم بذلك
الوضع سيتدهور
حول الخطوط الحمراء
ستمحى في الاتجاه الاخرى
اريد ان ادعو الجميع
الى السماء
التي طردت
ان اللحظه الاصعب في حياتي
اريد ان ادعو مجددا الى تهدئه الخواطر
ووقت العنف
واعتقد باننا سنجد الطريق قريبا
للحوار
نعتدي الواحد على الاخر لا يوجد لنا دوله
اخرى
شكرا لكم
اذا مشاهدينا استمعنا لهذه الكلمه
لبنيامين نتناول رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي
هو يتحدث عن الازمه الداخليه في اسرائيل
والمظاهرات التي خرجت وتخرج منذ فتره
لمتظاهرين ضد ما يعرف باصلاح النظام
القضائي في اسرائيل وهو القانون المثير
للجدل اليوم الشرطه الاسرائيليه اشتبكت مع
عدد من المتظاهرين نتنياهو قال ان
المعارضه الاسرائيليه تتصرف بدون مسؤوليه
وهي تحرض على التظاهر وقال المتظاهرون ضد
الاصلاح اعتدوا اصلاح القضاء اعتدوا اذا
على الشرطه وقال قبل ذلك بانه لا يقبل
بالعنف في اي مكان ان كان في حواره ولا في
اي مكان اخر